julien vercueil c'est déjà le sixième
train de sanctions mais cette fois on
s'attaque au pétrole russe est une étape
importante dans cette tentative d'
asphyxie et que ne reprenne de
l'économie russe
alors je crois pas qu'il faille parler
de tentatives d' asphyxie de l'économie
de la russie en fait il s'agit d'essayer
de couper les moyens de l'état russe de
poursuivre sa guerre ce qui est assez
différent de la notion d' asphyxie de
l'économie la russie qu'en fait pour
l'instant en 2021 les le pétrole et les
produits pétroliers représenté 37 % des
exportations totales de la russie ce qui
veut dire 37 % des recettes en devises
qui sera ensuite nécessaire pour les
entreprises et l'état russe pour par
exemple acheter des technologies
étrangères ou des produits étrangers qui
leur permettront de financer leur effort
de guerre etc c'est aussi une partie
importante des recettes de l'état russe
puisque l'état prélève des recettes sur
à la fois les taxes sur les exportations
de pétrole est à la fois sur les
bénéfices des grandes entreprises qui
exportent ce pétrole dont vous voyez
c'est aussi une façon d'appuyer sur deux
sources importantes de financement de la
guerre en ce qui concerne le gaz
qu'elles sont les chiffres pour ce qui
concerne le gaz c'est moins important le
gaz représente à peu près de la moitié
entre la moitié et un tiers de ce qu'ils
te ce que représente le plus le pétrole
et produits pétroliers en 2021 c'était
10% des exportations totales de la
russie on parle donc d'un délai de six
mois pour ce cet embargo sur le pétrole
russe plus long pour d'autres pays
indépendants du pétrole russe comme la
hongrie c'est logique de laisser
finalement certains pays s'adapter à la
situation
oui je crois qu'il y a plusieurs
éléments de logique qu'il faut trouver
derrière cette idée de progressivité et
de gradation d'abord il ya l'idée de ne
pas provoquer un choc sur le marché
mondial puisque
l'union européenne est un des plus gros
consommateurs mondiaux de pétrole et
donc
proposer une redirection aussi radicale
des orientations d'approvisionnement ça
voudrait dire un choc sur sur les prix
internationaux de l'énergie une
augmentation très forte donc là on est
graduelle donc on annonce à l'avance ce
que l'on va faire ce qui permet au
marché de s'adapter la deuxième raison
c'est que chaque pays européen n'est pas
dans la même situation vis-à-vis du
pétrole le pétrolier du pétrole russe
donc par exemple vous avez des pays
qu'ils ne dépendent qu'à 5 6 % ou 10 %
de leurs approvisionnements d'autres qui
qui en dépendent a plus la moitié donc
ça permet à chacun d'avoir aussi des
solutions d'adaptation différencier et
puis le dernier élément qui me semble
aussi très très important c'est que avec
le passage du temps il y aura vis-à-vis
des prod des producteurs de pétrole ses
vis-à-vis de l'iran vis-à-vis de
l'arabie saoudite des négociations de
plus en plus forte qu'il faut qu'il
faudra mener pour les amener à augmenter
leurs quantités produites pour l'instant
ça n'est pas possible soit pour des
raisons politiques soit pour des raisons
économiques soit pour des raisons
techniques par exemple pour le venezuela
qui aurait pu être un gros producteur
son système de production pétroliers
dans un tel état qu'il ne serait pas
capable d'augmenter fortement sa
production bien qu'il en ait la capacité
donc il faut donner du temps à tous ces
producteurs là pour absorber le choc de
la redirection des importations de
l'union européenne et je crois que c'est
de là que se trouve la rationalité de la
progressivité donner du temps aussi aux
européens pour se tourner vers d'autres
partenaires pour finalement compensé ces
pertes de pétrole russe
exactement comme je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure il y a une différence entre un
pays qui dépend à 60 % de ses
importations de pétrole russe est un
pays qui dépend à 10 ou 15% donc pour le
2ème l'impact de sa redirection sur
d'autres marchés pourra être minime pour
d'autres il va falloir trouver les
sources d'approvisionnement même
logistique tout simplement ne pas
dépendre de tel ou tel fournisseur
russe ça veut dire
signé des contrats avec d'autres
fournisseurs et donc ça ça prend du
temps et on peut légitimement retourner
la question s'il a réussi neuf en plus
son pétrole le européen à qui il va
t-elle le vendre
ça c'est une très grosse question ça
c'est une très grosse question
évidemment le temps gagné pour les
européens c'est aussi du temps gagné
pour la russie pour essayer d'obtenir
d'autres contrats d'autres d'autres
clients mais ses clients ils n'ont pas
la taille cas là l'union européenne
l'union européenne c'est un des plus
gros consommateurs
donc il va falloir multiplier les
contacts pour les russes avec des
consommateurs plus petit ce qui va
prendre beaucoup de temps est ce qu'il
sera difficile ce qui l'est qui est
possible c'est que la russie disons
fasse ce qu'elle a fait avec l'inde au
tout début de la guerre c'est à dire
qu'elles proposent des décotes sur le
pétrole qu'elle vend de façon à lille
en trop voilà elle est dans quel état
aujourd'hui cette économie russe deux
mois et demi après le déclenchement de
la guerre en ukraine et après donc ses
cinq premiers trains de sanctions
européen
on ne peut pas dire qu'elle aille bien
l'économie de la russie est dans une
situation qui
est sur le point d'entrer en récession
alors on ne peut parler de récession
qu'après un certain temps donc on n'a
pas suffisamment de recul pour parler de
récession mais les prévisions
économiques qui sont soit des prévisions
d'organismes internationaux soit des
prévisions
d'organismes russe nationaux table sur
une chute d'environ 10% du produit
intérieur brut donc 10% du produit
interne brut c'est une énorme crise une
crise qui est de l'ordre de celles que
la la russie a connu par exemple en 2008
suite à la crise financière ou en 1998
suite au défaut de paiement souverain
alors ça c'est le premier point
maintenant c'est une crise qui sera
aussi inflationnistes c'est à dire que
il y a eu une augmentation très forte
des prix dans les premiers mois qui ont
suivi l'entrée en guerre et cette
augmentation des prix même si elle va se
tasser va avoir un effet d'inertie donc
on table aujourd'hui sur une inflation
d'environ 20% sur l'ensemble de l'année
2022 et début de 2023 ce qui est très
important parce que
cette inflation va rogner le pouvoir
d'achat essentiellement des catégories
les plus vulnérables de la population
russe des personnes dont les salaires
sont les plus faibles et ce sera donc
des conséquences sociales très
importantes qu'il va falloir prendre en
charge par le budget de l'état russe ça
va donc coûter très cher à l'état russe
et l'état russe n'est plus en mesure
d'emprunter vis-à-vis de l'étranger
puisqu'il a été mis au ban des des
emprunteurs par les occidentaux donc il
y a des réserves qui reste évidemment
mobilisables une partie ont été gelés
comme vous le savez par les pays
occidentaux mais il va y avoir une
quadrature du cercle très difficile à
résoudre au fur et à mesure que la crise
va s'enfoncer et va se préciser en
russie pour les autorités russes merci
beaucoup julien vercueil d'avoir accepté
ce midi l'invitation de france 24